para ampliar más sobre el inicio de
temporada de pogačar vamos a conversar
con el periodista Lionel buseri
especialista en ciclismo bienvenido
Leonel a France 24
Buenas noches Luis Buenas noches a todos
yonel te pregunto estamos viendo un poco
ashare dominante en las primeras
competencias en las que ha participado
Qué cambios hizo el pedalista esloveno
que ha manifestado que quiere estar en
por lo menos dos grandes vueltas este
año
lo que vemos es una dominación enorme de
tadeige desde el inicio de la temporada
acabo de de ganar su su novena carrera
en 13 días de carrera lo que demuestra
una Un inicio de temporada increíble lo
que ha cambiado quizás entre este año y
la el año pasado la Quizás es que ha
ganado en es más maduro y ya estaré por
agachar es más Quizás más
tranquilo en la bici comete quizás menos
errores lo que le permite a pesar de
esta temporada de una forma increíble y
lo que demostró en la París Niza fue
este cambio en su forma de de competir
que todavía es muy agresivo que sigue
atacando muy duro a los animales pero
también con más Quizás estrategia que es
menos impulsivo y que también tiene más
táctica lo que le permitió dominar a
Jonas binglegart que él que fue el
corredor que le que le derrotó en el gol
de Francia del año pasado precisamente
Leonel quisiera hablarte de vinecard
este corredor que como vieja puntas ganó
el Tour del año pasado y que presionó
apodachar a lo largo de esta París Niza
y Cómo podemos evaluar entonces lo que
ha sido para él lo que va de temporada
también ganó en España una competencia
había muchas expectativas sobre
porque sí salió de de una temporada 2022
increíble con su Victoria en el Tour de
Francia lo que no estaba despejado y que
también empezó muy bien la temporada
pero lo vimos con límites en este en
este Tour de la París Niza y sorprendió
porque lo pensábamos más cercano al
nivel de de thetage o gachar y lo que
hemos visto es que está bastante lejos
ahí de de de pocacha terminó a más de un
minuto y medio de hecho gacha cuando
todo el mundo pensaba que los dos y
estaban muy cercano en uno del otro
vimos ahí que hay una diferencia enorme
en este en esta carrera entre los dos y
hasta el punto que no termina segundo
sino tercero de la París misa y lo que
es un golpe bastante duro para
binglegart que es un chico que quizás
tiene unas dificultades al nivel mental
que se sorprendió de ganar el Tour de
Francia el año pasado y que vamos a ver
cómo va a reaccionar esta en las
próximas carreras y si se van a
enfrentar antes del Tour de Francia 2023
o no ahora por otro lado también hay que
hablar de otro que presionó a lo largo
de esta París Niza a tadepo gachar
estamos hablando de David este corredor
que no tuvo un 2022 importante pero que
pareciera que ha cambiado su estrategia
de Cara a lo que es la temporada de 2023
para mí es la gran sorpresa de esta
semana
todos los seguidores del ciclismo
estaban esperando una pelea entre
pocachar y dingar nadie pensaba que
David podía
juntarse a esta pelea y y estar casi al
nivel de no no lo superó pero está
estuvo muy cerca en varias en varias
etapas esta semana y es una sorpresa
parece que godú que tiene 26 años que es
un corredor francés Ah tomó mucha
confianza con su cuarto puesto del en el
Tour de Francia del año pasado que para
muchos no es tan importante pero para él
parece que le le hizo un cambio al nivel
de su mentalidad y de su confianza para
pensar que sí podía estar peleando con
los los mejores del del lote al nivel
mundial que son los eslovenos o o Jonas
de El danés y demostró esta semana que
sí podía estar a este nivel Y adelantar
a Jonas que recordamos ganó el año
pasado el Tour de Francia y estar a
menos de un minuto de tadeche o gacha
que es un excelente resultado para para
David y vamos a ver
cómo sigue su temporada con esta esta
nueva confianza que tiene el joven
francés ahora quisiera hablar de otro
esloveno primos en la semana destacó en
la terreno adriático en Italia él está
pensado para participar Precisamente en
el giro de este año cómo lo ves de cara
esa gran competencia de 2023
creo que que
primos oro glitches también la el hombre
fuerte de del momento
en el ciclismo y demostró que ya está
casi listo para el giro que que empezar
a a principios de mayo en Italia y ganó
esta semana tres etapas ganó la general
de chileno adriático que era su su
carrera de de reinicio de temporada
después de una temporada que fue
complicado al final para para que se
cayó en el Tour de Francia se cayó en la
vuelta tuvo que operarse de la del
hombro entonces fue muy difícil y no
sabíamos bien cómo iba a empezar de
nuevo esta temporada y demostró que la
empresa muy bien y que hace parte de Los
favoritos para el giro de Italia de este
año y no va a ir al Tour de Francia
Muchísimas gracias a Leonel por
ofrecernos este amplio análisis sobre el
ciclismo internacional
mucho gusto Luis